there are good predictions and there are
bad predictions
and there are bad predictions and there
are terrible predictions
and there are terrible predictions and
then
there are the biden administration's
predictions about afghanistan
which were given to us by biden
secretary of state anthony blinken just
days ago
i don't think that uh the fact that our
forces are withdrawing one we're not
withdrawing we're staying uh the embassy
is staying our programs are staying
we're working to make sure that other
partners stay we're building all of that
up and uh whatever happens in
afghanistan if there is a significant
deterioration uh insecurity um that
could well happen we've discussed this
uh before um i don't think it's going to
be something that happens from a friday
to a monday so i wouldn't um necessarily
equate the departure of our forces
in july august or by early september
with some kind of immediate uh
deterioration uh in the uh in the
situation
in case you missed it this weekend
between friday and monday afghanistan
fell to the taliban it is actually
impressive how
perfectly wrong
the prediction of the biden
administration was this after joe biden
said it was not inevitable that the
taliban would come back also just days
ago completely wrong republicans are
blaming biden democrats are blaming
trump biden's blaming trump trump is
blaming biden and once blamed obama
obama blamed bush the problem though
goes a lot deeper than democrats versus
republicans
afghanistan is not just a god-forsaken
desert in the graveyard of empires
afghanistan is the symbol of america's
identity crisis i'm michael knowles the
michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from yurian van
doyne who says wouldn't surprise me when
the taliban gets a blue check mark right
away after signing up for twitter that
wouldn't surprise me at all actually the
fact that the taliban is on twitter and
the former president of the united
states is not
tells you a whole lot about this
identity crisis that we're having as
americans it really sometimes all the
terrible news makes you want to just pop
in some earbuds and tune it all out
which when i do that i always want to go
to raycon look i have tried the other
earbuds and let me just tell you
am very happy that i got my pair of
raycons ray cons are the best way to
listen they come with a bunch of gel
tips for your comfort unlike other
brands they don't make you look like a
bug with the stems sticking out they've
got 32 hour battery life so you can
listen to what you want when you want
for a long time they're not glitchy like
other brands okay i don't want to name
names but i i'm just saying
i love raycon's they're terrific they
started half the price of other premium
audio brands they sound just as good i
could not possibly recommend raycons
more highly by the way they come with a
45-day happiness guarantee so you cannot
lose give them a try seriously you will
thank me later i love them great way to
listen to your favorite podcast
him your favorite
uh audiobook your favorite music create
your own soundtrack right now with
raycon my listeners will get 15 off
their raycon order at buyracon.com
knowles that's by raycon.com knowles to
save 15
off of raycons byraycon.com
knowles go check out raycon today
what happened to afghanistan you've very
likely been following the news so i'll
just give you a very brief recap because
i'm sure you're hearing lots of
conflicting stuff for instance from the
biden administration you're hearing uh
denials and silence and from reality and
from the reporters who are on the ground
and from everybody else you were seeing
this disaster unfold so what happened is
afghanistan's sort of fake president who
is being propped up by the u.s ashraf
ghani
gave up power he just he gave it up it
wasn't working he ran away to tajikistan
this means that the the afghan
government that the united states has
been building for 20 years is deader
than disco it folded like a house of
cards
then
you've got the the interim government
now is being run by the taliban taliban
commander mala abdul ghani bharadar the
u.s embassy in kabul
this was now two days ago suspended all
operations told americans to shelter in
place
uh it was hearing of gunfire at the
kabul airport so absolute chaos total
surrender you saw helicopters actually
landing at the embassy to lift people
away just like they did with the fall of
saigon in the end of the vietnam war
you are
seeing the taliban enter kabul from all
sides kabul capital of afghanistan
taliban totally taking over
joe biden has now approved more troops
to go over there to try to secure the
exits this is not more troops to stop
the taliban that's over that's that's
not going to happen anymore it's just
troops to go in to make sure that
americans and at least some of our
afghan allies don't get killed on the
way out
initially the u.s was going to pull out
of afghanistan on september 11th on the
20th anniversary of the attacks seems a
little dark i don't know why i mean just
from an optics pr standpoint doesn't
make a lot of sense but that timetable
has been moved up it wasn't moved up by
the state department it wasn't moved up
by the pentagon it wasn't moved up by
the white house it was moved up by the
taliban because the taliban knew that
the american forces were leaving and so
they weren't going to waste any time
there was an expression from the very
beginning of the afghanistan
i don't even know what to call it was it
a war was it an occupation was it a
liberation i don't i don't know what it
was and unfortunately neither did
america which is why we lost but from
the very beginning of whatever we've
been doing in afghanistan the expression
has been that the americans have the
watches but the taliban's got the time
that the americans are really obviously
very technically proficient they can
game all these things out but the fact
is the taliban are just going to be
there and then eventually the americans
are going to leave and the taliban is
going to come right back in
20 years
20 years in that godforsaken desert what
did we achieve
that's what as as
americans are watching the footage of
the chinook landing and taking off and
the embassy falling and the whole
government we spent zillions of dollars
building collapsing overnight they were
saying what did we
achieve
it's not nothing we we killed bin laden
took about a decade to do it but we
killed bin laden also not in afghanistan
but in pakistan but surely our presence
in afghanistan helped help to do that so
we killed bin laden and
yeah okay i guess that's about it i
guess we
we arrested some terrorists although we
didn't even kill a lot of those
terrorists so now the terrorists are
just being released we arrested a lot of
these taliban guys and then they were
released as well so
so that's it
20 years in the place
to get a guy that we killed in pakistan
where oh where
did everything go wrong
i know that republicans
are
very eager to blame biden for all of
this and trump is doing that too he's
saying bye biden's messing everything up
you famously remember uh barack obama
was quoted as saying uh never
underestimate the amount
to which joe biden can f everything up
this was during the 2020 campaign and
that's true but i don't i don't really
blame biden
i do sure could he as a tactical matter
could he have handled it better i guess
so but i don't really blame biden i
don't really blame
trump or obama
i do blame bush a little bit more uh but
i sort of blame the broader ethos in
america that the national identity
crisis and i've pinpointed i think the
exact
moment
when everything went wrong and that was
during george w bush's second inaugural
address
so this is in early 2005 when george w
bush redefined not just the mission
afghanistan which was already kind of
ill-defined but redefined
the relationship of national security
to
broader ideals and redefined the very
purpose of america herself
for as long as whole regions of the
world simmer in resentment and tyranny
prone to ideologies that feed hatred
and excuse murder
violence will gather
and multiply in destructive power
and cross the most defended borders
and raise a mortal threat okay so there
this was the diagnosis that bush made he
said as long as there is tyranny
anywhere anywhere that that will pose an
existential threat the the the tyrants
and the people inspired by the tyrants
will fly overseas and attack the
american homeland
which is a ridiculous claim that's just
not true
i guess it was true in afghanistan which
created a safe haven for terrorists i
mean i understand why bush made this
observation but then he generalized it
to all what all tyrannies if any
government is not a madisonian style
democracy bush seems to imply then
they're going to come and attack the
american homeland that's just not true
it's not true think of all the tyrannies
in the world china russia russia even at
this time was an autocratic tyranny and
they hadn't really directly threatened
the united states in in decades
all those tin pot dictatorships in latin
america they're not directly really
threatening the united states so but
that was the diagnosis we have to stop
tyranny anywhere and so what's bush
going to do about it
he is going to eliminate tyranny from
the world
the survival of liberty in our land
increasingly depends on the success of
liberty in other lands the best hope for
peace in our world
is the expansion of freedom in all the
world america's vital interests and our
deepest beliefs are now won
we have proclaimed that every man and
woman on this earth has rights
and dignity
and matchless value
because they bear the image of the maker
of heaven and earth across the
generations we have proclaimed the
imperative of self-government
because no one is fit to be a master
and no one deserves to be a slave
advancing these ideals is the mission
that created our nation
it is the honorable achievement of our
fathers
now it is the urgent requirement of our
nation's security
and the calling of our time
so it is the policy of the united states
to seek and support the growth of
democratic movements
and institutions in every nation
and culture
with the ultimate goal of ending tyranny
in our world
the mission of the united states in the
world imperative for her national
security for her very survival the
existential mission of the united states
is to eliminate
evil from the world
a messianic mission
unfortunately difficult to live up to
that because it's utopian
you know when you want to protect
yourself from bad guys or even good guys
that you just don't want to see i would
recommend checking out ring we all want
to protect our homes and i'm not just
talking about protecting our homes
against burglars okay i'm talking about
protecting our homes against
in-laws all right or or whoever else
shows up that maybe you just want you
just want to know who's there well with
ring you can see and speak to whoever is
at your door easily from your phone
whether you are in your home whether
you're at the office whether you're on
vacation i know a lot of people are
going away around this time of the year
you can always keep an eye not just on
your front door by the way but on every
inch of your house
ring gives me great peace of mind i was
i was away for the day
on saturday i was just i had to go up
flew up to another friend's wedding and
i just feel great knowing that sweet
little elise and cute baby june will
know who's outside the door before they
open that door great piece of mind makes
a great housewarming gift because it's
top of the line technology and not very
expensive protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today build a system
that is right for your home have it up
and running in minutes ring.com knowles
that is ring.com
knowles go check out ring today
george w bush's second inaugural address
in early 2005
is called the freedom speech
it used the words freedom or free or
liberty
49 times in the speech
it it was a redefinition of america's
role in the world
america was not going to be merely a
nation that kept to herself
america was not even going to be
an empire that was
taking territory to secure her own
merely her own interests or to just grab
other resources or anything like that
america was going to be
a purely benevolent empire
the only benefit america was going to
get was securing national security
but what america was going to give to
the rest of the world
was to eliminate tyranny topple every
dictatorship autocracy oligarchy
anything that did not
seem to be perfect self-government in
the view of the american experience
that is a big claim that you're going to
do that
a fundamental redefinition of the
country so what does afghanistan mean
because afghanistan is
the test of this
afghanistan is the consequence of this
idea and the test of this idea
i i think it is
ridiculous that joe biden is blaming
donald trump that is really pathetic so
much for the adults in the room so much
for the buck stops here joe biden
immediately when under his watch the
thing falls apart so it was trump's
fault he blamed trump it wasn't me
please it was the orange man he's
responsible for everything
likewise i don't think it's really
biden's fault don't think it's obama's
fault
in a way i think it's bush's fault
but more broadly
it's the fault of the american people to
not really know what it is
that we are
and most especially it's the fault of
the elite that are running the
institutions in the state department all
the other places it's a lot deeper
though than it is republicans versus
democrats there are two main
opinions here
that come down on afghanistan the one is
the american nationalist position which
is pull out stop the forever wars what
the hell are we doing in afghanistan 20
years later get bring the troops home
enough is enough
the other
is the
empire position the imperial position
well of course we've got to stay in
afghanistan we got to stay there we got
to prevent another 911 at the very least
we gotta you know make sure that the
girls can go to school we gotta
we we've just got to stay there because
the taliban are bad we're good and so
it's going to be better for everyone if
we're in afghanistan
so it's a conflict between nationalists
and imperialists and i gotta tell you
i'm sympathetic to both points of view
i'm sympathetic to the point of view of
hey let's do a little nation building at
home hey america's collapsing in the
homeland so let's focus a little more on
america let's focus more on detroit and
less on kandahar right but i'm also
sympathetic to the imperial point of
view i don't think that the taliban has
any right to govern afghanistan i don't
think it's a violation of the rights of
these islamists that we're not letting
them run their country or that we
weren't and i have no problem conquering
other lands if if i think it's in our
interest and if we think it's for the
best
but then the really hard question that i
don't see anyone really talking about
here is
if we're going to have an empire
what is that empire going to look like
the the way that i think you know that
even the elites
recognize that america doesn't want this
liberal empire is they always hide the
ball they never say whenever you say
okay how much longer are we going to be
in afghanistan they'll always say wait
just a little longer just no we
shouldn't pull out like this we've just
got to stay there until the afghan
government is sufficiently strong which
by the way is never going to happen it
folded in like six hours it was after 20
20 years of building it up it folds in
less than a day so that was never going
to happen so the the honest answer from
the liberal imperialists is
we're just gonna stay there forever
we're gonna have a small presence there
forever and that's it now afghanistan's
gonna be a territory that is perpetually
occupied by the united states okay if
that's your position that that then be
honest about it but they won't be honest
about it because they know that
americans don't want a liberal empire
because what is that what freedom are we
spreading
that's when george bush makes the
freedom speech the liberty speech the
question is what kind of liberty are we
talking about
are we talking about
a sort of christian empire like we saw
from spain or portugal or britain are we
talking about spreading the gospel to
new lands and and spreading the vision
that made the western civilization that
we all love
no i don't i don't think we are
the west now is largely secular we don't
speak in those kinds of terms anymore
the empire that we would be spreading is
a liberal empire
and so
what what are we doing in in afghanistan
are we
are we there to make sure
that the afghan people have the liberty
to have drag queen story hour in every
single library in kabul
is that it because if that's the case
then i don't i don't want any part of
that we need the liberty to make sure
that every every woman in kabul can dye
her hair pink and get a gender studies
degree no uh that i don't think that's a
good idea
now sure there's a lot of there's a lot
of gray area between the taliban you
know locking everyone up and under this
very restrictive code and
this radical conclusion of liberalism
but what is it what are we doing what
are we spreading
is it freedom as the founding fathers
would have understood it or is it
freedom as the hippies of today would
understand it
what if we don't have the answer to that
we by the way you're going to hear this
this one objective before we move on
from afghanistan this one objection that
i keep hearing from the liberal
imperialists the one who want to stay
who want to stay in afghanistan forever
but don't want to admit it
they keep saying well hold on we're
pulling troops out of afghanistan what
do you think we should pull troops out
of korea
what do you think we should pull troops
out of germany we have troops all over
the world sure we have troops all over
the world but if we pull the troops out
of germany the country isn't going to
collapse
if we pull the troops out of korea the
country isn't going to collapse for that
matter
the occupation of afghanistan was
categorically different than us having
bases on in various parts of the world
but we don't even know what it was
what was the war what was the victory
the reason we lost in afghanistan it's
not because soldiers didn't make great
sacrifices it's because we had no idea
what victory was
initially it was to go in and kill the
guys who flew planes into the building
and who trained them and then
and then what
we're not going to nation build then we
then we did nation build but we didn't
want to admit we were nation building
then we were going to form a
national security force in afghanistan
well how do you have a national security
force if there's no nation
and then it's but then it became about
sending girls to school which is that's
fine i mean i'm all for all for that i
guess but we're really gonna create an
empire so that we can send girls to
school in some god-forsaken region of
afghanistan what are we doing
you could we couldn't win that war
because we didn't know what we wanted
because as a country we don't know what
we want because we don't know what we
want to be and i think
although the elites may still agree with
the george w bush kind of liberal
imperialist wilsonian progressive vision
of just
spread this
pie in the sky vision of freedom all
over the world i don't think the
american people want that
this is why increasingly republicans and
democrats have both had to campaign
against that vision the american people
don't like that idea very much by the
way the the other scaremongering you're
hearing right now about the pull out of
afghanistan is that
all these terrorists are being set free
the taliban's coming in and they're
setting free all of these some of these
al qaeda prisoners that were being held
there and now they're going to return to
the battlefield
that's bad that's too bad taliban
overran bagram air base freed those
prisoners
am i the only one who's wondering why
those super duper dangerous al-qaeda
terrorists were still alive we've been
in the country occupying it for 20 years
why didn't we kill them all
be oh because
it wasn't it wasn't a war
it wasn't a war and it wasn't an
occupation it was a military involvement
that was the euphemism
some of these taliban guys were held by
the united states and we just let them
go or they were held by our allies or
sort of allies and then we just let them
go
if we were serious about fighting and
winning a war they would all be dead but
they're not dead because we weren't
really fighting a war so now what what
we're ending i guess is not really a war
it's just
very confused no one is more confused
than the american political leadership
who was supposed to be running the war
and by the way i mean this is going to
have this is going to have terrible
effects for national security down the
road there's no you can't just let a ton
of terrorists who are who have sworn
that they're going to try to destroy the
united states you can't just let them
all out and then give them a safe haven
and then just assume nothing bad is
going to happen so it will have national
security implications but the problem is
our genius ruling elite that got all the
predictions wrong about
well really about everything but
especially about afghanistan and
that that now are you know
trying to manage this
catastrophe they're not so worried about
the terrorists in al-qaeda
as they are about the terrorists in maga
hats
they are i'm not this is not an
exaggeration our
federal agencies that were some of which
were founded after 9 11 to fight against
these these islamist bad guys in the
middle east
are now saying that the real threat
is not from some guy in a turban and a
beard and in the taliban the real threat
is from a guy
in a in a trump shirt with a maga hat
and an american flag the real terror
threat is you
if you want to hear
more of these dire warnings i would
recommend you go check out the morning
wire subscribe and listen to morning
wire on apple podcast spotify anywhere
else you listen to podcasts so you don't
miss a beat if you like what you hear
leave a five star review and tell the
podcast platforms that conservative news
belongs at number one on the charts also
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two to the daily wire studios to see
candace live
go to dailywire.com subscribe with code
vip to get 25 off be automatically
entered for a chance to win the vip
experience but hurry this deal is going
away after wednesday so act fast to get
your membership discount and a chance to
win dailywire.com
subscribe get 25 off with code vip
we'll be right back with a lot more
i don't know why people are so worried
about terrorism coming from the taliban
or coming from al qaeda or coming from
all of those terrorists who say that
they want to destroy our country
nbc news
reporting on
new missives from the department of
homeland security
remind us that the terror threat
is not those guys in al qaeda the real
terror threat
is you a new terror alert has been
issued by homeland security tonight pete
williams is here pete what do we know
about this
well dhs says this new terrorism
advisory is not based on any actual
threats or plots but it says there's a
rise in anti-government rhetoric some of
it is opposition to covet public health
rules like mask and vaccine measures
some calls for violent action are based
on claims of election fraud or a belief
that donald trump can be reinstated and
dhs says the coming 20th anniversary of
the 9 11 attacks and religious holidays
later this year could be catalyst for
violence the last terror advisory was
issued in may it expired today this new
one says domestic extremism remains a
threat priority lester that's the
priority if you think that maybe there
were some shenanigans in the 2020
election you know the 2020 election
where
they got rid of all the voter integrity
measures beforehand
if not all of them a great many of them
you know the 2020 election where the
election officials in pennsylvania
overtly violated the state constitution
by permitting widespread mail and
ballots you know the election in 2020 in
georgia where just one batch finally was
subject to an audit and it had a
widespread double counting of ballots we
actually saw it we can actually look at
the ballots you know that one
you know
that election in 2020 where there were
just ballot drop boxes and motor voter
permissions and ballot harvesting
and where the voting just magically
stopped at various points in the middle
of the night then it sort of started
again days later and it took days and
days and weeks and weeks to figure out
who you remember that if you
you
you terrorist if you raise any questions
about that
you are a far greater threat
than osama bin laden
if you raise questions oh what was the
other way if you're
if you're anti-mask
if you think that maybe a handful of
unelected eggheads
should not
be able to completely upend our way of
life and take away our civil liberties
and upend the american tradition
yeah you you're probably a terrorist and
that's that's a far greater threat than
anyone else did you notice what
what they said at the top of that
warning and nbc as the sort of
propaganda mouthpiece of the liberal
regime reading the threats from dhs
they said that there are no actual
threats or plots so that the current
guidelines that classify half of america
as terrorists classify any conservatives
as terrorists
that
is not based on anything in reality
it's just based on i don't know what
some guys at dhs
sort of think
about you know hypothetically
we're going to spread liberty abroad oh
yes as long as there's a tyranny
anywhere in the world we are going to go
fight it because our national security
depends on it also if you question
anything about the regime you're a
terrorist
we're going to go we've got to go to
afghanistan because
we're going to spread all that wonderful
liberty i you know i sort of feel like
liberty has taken a hit in america have
you felt that way
you know because like you haven't been
able to go to work in a long time
hopefully you know hopefully you were in
one of the fields that didn't get
totally shut down during the lockdowns
but it was capricious it changed every
day you might not have been able to go
to church for large portions of last
year
you have to muzzle yourself when you go
out in public if you say anything that's
really critical of the regime that
dissents really in any way from the
leftist orthodoxy you'll be you'll be
de-platformed you'll be removed from the
public square you might be placed on a
no-fly list and now dhs says you might
be labeled a terrorist
can't wait to spread that liberty
all that liberty hmm
seems strong maybe before we
go build up liberty and the other
nations maybe we should build it up here
as well it's not just democrats who are
doing this by the way there is that that
jokester adam kinsinger he is one of the
court jester conservatives he's a he's a
republican he's a elected official as a
republican but he's really
just a prop of the liberal regime his
entire point is to the entire purpose of
his political career is to make a show
of being a republican to appear as
though there is opposition within the
dominant political order but actually
whenever it matters he all he ever does
is give support to the broader liberal
establishment so kinzinger goes on cnn
of course and he's talking to anderson
cooper of course and he's
defending the dhs view that conservative
republicans are terrorists when you look
at online rhetoric and you look at
chatter that's happening and you look at
you know maybe a hundred people post
insane comments like bring out the
gallows even if only two of those out of
the 100 are serious that leads to
violence i think what the biggest
concern is
is all this talk a lot of times just you
know people trying to sound tough on the
internet but that ends up kind of
feeding itself and particularly when
people start brainwashing folks with the
election was stolen look at what all
these patriotic people did in the 1700s
this is the same thing the mask mandate
is basically the equivalent of not
allowing you to practice your religion
you know which is
1776 taxation without representation
ultimately that does grow into action
and it's a real concern so but before we
get to his broader stupid point i do
want to focus in on his on his minor
stupid points he's he's suggesting that
somehow the american revolution was
based on people not being able to
practice their religion which he's
getting his history confused here that
was but then he corrects himself because
then he
i think he realizes that wait that
actually wasn't part of it so he says
you know they're they're comparing
having to muzzle yourself at infinitum
you know at the whims of some random
technocrat they're comparing that with
no taxation without representation as
though that's just as bad and i think
look maybe i'm giving him too much
credit
but i think he's realizing as he's
saying this oh wait a minute
having to muzzle yourself indefinitely
not through the processes of the
constitutional order and the elected
government but because some random
bureaucrat just orders you to
that actually
is a bit more egregious than a tax hike
isn't it
to me it is i don't
when i think of you know i'm trying to
put myself in the mindset of 1776 and i
don't have representation in parliament
exactly but you know i'm having my taxes
raised a little bit to pay for a war
that was fought on my shores and
and i compare that to
having to
muzzle myself forever not being able to
push back against that if i even try to
voice my political opposition to that
i'll be labeled a terrorist by the
dominant regime also by agencies that
are unelected and i have no recourse
against that actually does seem worse
that actually that actually does raise
some questions about the political order
and so kenzinger is trying to work his
way
through all of this but
kenzinger's
broader point is that if you question
any of this you're you're a terrorist
this can lead to really large-scale
terrible
stuff it's not even just the
conservative adults
it's the kids if the kids
in any way disobey dr fauci
they're not just terrorists but
murderers a member of an oklahoma school
board just came out during a school
board meeting and said that if kids do
not wear the masks in class they could
be murderers it's just not okay
for kids to commit murder by coming to
school without a mask and when it comes
down to it
it's possible
they will ch they will cause a death of
another child
because they come to school without a
mask
these are the people leading us
and you know this woman is hysterical
and not the brightest bulb in the pack
but i'm not sure that she's so much
so much more ignorant or so much uh
stupider than adam kinzinger or than
anthony blinken or any of the ruling
elite that are just getting all of this
stuff wrong first of all to this woman's
point
she just obviously doesn't know what
murder is murder involves intention so
if she's saying that kids are killing
people because they're not wearing masks
again also a ridiculous claim but that
would not be murder so she certainly
doesn't know what she's talking about
and then then to go out and she's saying
look if a kid shows up to school without
a mask
he could spread
the coronavirus
because the kids are not vaccinated
right but we've also been told that
vaccinated people are spreading the
coronavirus
and we've also been told that the masks
don't offer perfect protection against
spreading the coronavirus by anthony
fauci actually of all people
so
what she's saying is
the kids could spread the coronavirus
and then if it spreads far enough you
know someone might might die from that
and maybe the masks
don't offer perfect protection to stop
that and the vaccines certainly don't
offer perfect protection to stop that
but still the kids can be involved in it
this would be
like saying
that if a guy
on an assembly line in detroit
polishes the windows on a brand new car
and then the car makes it to a
dealership somewhere else in the united
states and someone
looks at that car and says gosh that
look how beautiful that shiny windshield
is you know i think i'm going to go buy
that car and then that guy goes and buys
that car and he drives that car around
for a little bit and then maybe he
decides you know he's not going to uh
like that car anymore maybe he wants to
get a different grasp he goes and he
sells that car and he sells that car to
someone else and then that other person
goes and he goes to a bar one day and he
has a few too many drinks and he gets in
a car and he accidentally gets into a
car accident and somebody dies in that
car accident that windshield wiper
killed somebody
that got because that got way back on
the line he did a thing
and that resulted do you realize i mean
this is now the logic that the the kovid
people are foisting on all of us that
anything we any ordinary thing we do to
live our lives somewhere down the line
of causation could cause someone to die
and so you you are a murderer
it's not just on the covets i mean this
is this is their point on on dhs and the
terror threat of conservatives yeah
there's no threats yeah there's no
actual plots or anything but if someone
says that maybe there were shenanigans
in the 2020 election well that could
inspire someone else to maybe think
there's a problem with the government
that could inspire someone else and then
someone someday might throw a punch
against a guy at a bar and look he's a
terrorist
that logic is so muddy that logic is so
so
it's not credible
it's just
not credible
we used to have an idea in america that
you had some kind of personal liberty
and that we had political liberties and
this involves danger you know liberty
does involve some element of danger okay
when people are left to their own
devices to govern themselves and someone
the political community is left to
govern itself
there's the possibility that things
could go wrong but that's that's in the
nature of liberty
anthony fauci says
americans just need to push aside
all those concerns about personal
liberty
we've got to do mitigation
put aside all of these issues of concern
about liberties and personal liberties
and realize we have a common enemy and
that common enemy is the virus and we
really have to all pull together to get
on top of this otherwise we're going to
continue to suffer as we're seeing right
now that's you got to just push aside
your entire american way of life and
your tradition and all your civil
liberties and everything you hold dear
push it aside just for now
just for 15 days just for 15 months just
for 15 years just push it aside and then
someday we'll give you your power back
someday we'll give you your liberty back
oh by the way we also need to spread
liberty to every country on earth
how about we spread liberty to america
is there any is there any way that we
could have a liberating operation
are there is there any that would be
great i'd like it to be maybe through
our politics maybe we could do that
maybe we could retake some of our
political power vote out these awful
politicians fire these terrible
bureaucrats
shrink the power of these awful
would-be tyrants in the united states
we probably need to to agree on what
those words mean though we got to agree
what what do we mean by liberty freedom
authoritarianism what what do we mean by
those words because as long as they're
pie in the sky vague out out in the air
like george bush used at the second
inaugural
they're not going to mean anything in
practice
the director of the nih
he has identified the real enemy that we
face the real enemy that we face right
now it's not maybe it's not the taliban
maybe it's not even the coronavirus it's
misinformation
that is tearing us apart it's really
unfortunate that politics and
polarization have got in the way of a
simple public health measure this mask
that i'm holding has somehow become a
symbol that it never should have been
this is basically just a life-saving
medical device
and somehow it's now being seen as an
invasion of your personal liberty we
never should have gone there it's
heartbreaking for me as a person who's
not a politician i'm a scientist i'm a
public health person i'm a doctor to see
how mass have gotten into this very
strange place with parents and
others shouting about it we never should
allow that to happen if i have one thing
i'm worried about it's not just the
epidemic
of covet 19 it's the epidemic of
misinformation disinformation distrust
that is tearing us apart if
misinformation is a super spreader or
rather if misinformation is our is our
greatest public health threat then the
public health officials are the super
spreaders there's no there's no question
about that from the very beginning how
did how did there
become all of this confusion over the
masks oh i don't know do you think it
was because anthony fatchi told us masks
are dumb and don't do anything and you
shouldn't wear them at the start of the
coronavirus pandemic and then five
seconds later he said no actually you
should i was just telling you that so
that you wouldn't take them all from the
nurses but believe me i lied to you then
but believe me now
do you think that might have something
to do with the misinformation
worse than that worse than the the
cynical
political rhetoric that we hear
from from the head of the nih
is
this this really
i think honestly ignorant statement that
he's upset that the masks are
politicized
he says i'm not a politician
i'm just a public health
guy anything that is
public
is by definition political because those
words are synonyms if you if you are
setting
national policy
you are a politician if you're a private
doctor living in the country somewhere
who's just treating patients then you're
not a politician then you're just a
health guy but if you're in washington
dc running the national institutes of
health getting your paycheck from the
government setting national policy for
hundreds of millions of people you are a
politician so own up to it but they
don't want to own up to it
they don't want to acknowledge this this
is actually just like the afghanistan
issue they don't want to acknowledge
that they are imposing a way of life on
people they don't want to acknowledge
that they are making certain declarative
political statements and they are saying
that everyone's got to go along with
this and we are we are going to be the
empire we are going to be the order
so they just say no we're not uh
we're not in afghanistan to
occupy or to nation build no we're just
we're just kind of there we're just come
on this isn't political
we're not look when we tell
everyone to
muzzle themselves in public and
radically change their way of life and
and wear something that is clearly a
symbol
we're not
we're not doing that as in a political
way
whenever people tell you something's not
political recogni they say don't make
this about politics you know that they
are making it about politics
the other reason
i think that people
don't have a lot of faith in these guys
is that they themselves don't believe it
so first of all that guy who was clearly
in a tv studio while he was while he was
giving this interview wasn't wearing a
mask
i bet there was a camera operator in
that room but there were plenty of
people in that room
but he wasn't wearing a mask okay
because it would look ridiculous to have
the mask on on television right how
about obama's birthday party
none of those people were wearing masks
we have video of it even though the
video was quickly deleted now reportedly
there's a covid spike in martha's
vineyard martha's vineyard has a spike
in covid cases according to the daily
mail after barack obama's birthday party
it's the higher number of cases in a
week on the island since april
now am i blaming obama for this no i
don't think it really matters i just
don't think it's that big a deal clearly
obama doesn't think it's that big a deal
clearly none of the people at the party
think it's that big of a deal
so they're not
these guys are not practicing what
they're preaching we can see just
looking at their behavior and looking at
the insane rhetoric that they're voicing
on us that if a little kid doesn't wear
a mask he's a murderer we can just we
can just tell that the rhetoric is wrong
it's not true and they don't even
believe it themselves
they don't actually
care
and nevertheless it's the whole
bureaucracy pushing this stuff
jerome adams who is trump's former
surgeon general he was the one who early
on tweeted out he said st all caps stop
buying masks people multiple exclamation
points stop it don't buy the masks they
don't work don't stop wearing the masks
and then five seconds later said oh
actually you should wear the mask
they're very important so jerome adams
this guy completely
declined himself
he's come out and he said that that ron
desantis standing up against the mask
mandates that is unconscionable former
u.s surgeon general dr jerome adams
joins us now to talk about all this dr
adams good morning
good morning so florida's governor says
the state could withhold the salaries of
school officials who defies order to ban
mask mandates as a physician as a father
what's your reaction to that
well as a physician as a public health
expert it is deeply troubling that it
seems we're letting politics get in the
way
of protecting our our youth as a father
i quite frankly think it's
unconscionable i really do i think you
can't tie the hands of school and public
health officials uh based on
what you perceive to be the the reality
when your public health officials are
telling you they need these tools
it's unconscionable it's unconscionable
jerome adams since leaving the trump
administration since the end of the
trump administration he's become
basically a liberal commentator and he
goes on all the liberal networks and he
i think he even at one point suggested
that conservatives were racist or
something like he brought up
some kind of race hustling nonsense too
it just shows you i don't even i don't
care about what jerome's adam says ever
but what it shows you is
the whole bureaucracy including those
who were ostensibly serving under the
republicans
they're all kind of on the same page
and they don't seem to be on the same
page as the american people they all
seem to be clamping down on your civil
liberties and clamping down on your way
of life and clamping down on your
political rights even to question that
sort of thing
it
and and what can we do about that i
don't know we're not allowed i mean it's
taken us 20 years to get out of
afghanistan it's not because people
haven't tried they just it was just very
hard to overcome the inertia of being
there
we can't we haven't been able to
dislodge fauci or any of the other
people it's we
we have a problem of political power in
the united states and i think it comes
down to this question what are we are we
a nation that governs itself
or are we an empire projecting power
overseas and if we are an empire what
are we projecting what are they don't
seem like the traditional american
values what is it
what are we what is it that we stand for
these battles that we think are just
kind of these narrow battles over policy
or political parties it's not the
question is who are we as a country
before we try to remake afghanistan
let's figure out what america is first
i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
if you enjoyed this episode don't forget
to subscribe and if you want to help
spread the word please give us a five
star review and tell your friends to
subscribe we're available on apple
podcasts spotify and wherever else you
listen to podcasts also be sure to check
out the other daily wire podcasts
including the ben shapiro show the
andrew clavin show and the matt wall
show the michael knowles show is
produced by ben davies executive
producer jeremy boring our technical
director is austin stevens supervising
producer mathis glover production
manager pavel vadofsky editor and
associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by nika geneva michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021 on the matte wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show